here are the nominees for achievement in
makeup and hair styling
coming to america mike marino stacy
morris and carla farmer cruella nadia
stacy naomi don and julia vernon dune
donald moed louva
the eyes of tammy faye linda dowd
stephanie ingram and justin raleigh
house of gucci yarn lundstrom anna karen
lock and frederick s pieras
and the oscar goes to
the eyes of tammy faye
first of all
you just saw that we are in a group of
incredible nominees and everybody took a
moment to celebrate all of us and each
of us
before we stepped up here and i i so
love that is the true spirit of
what these awards are about um i want to
thank the academy
our branch managers
our biggest and
most dedicated collaborator jessica
chastain frecklefilm survived pictures
it does take a village we had incredible
teams we'd like to thank our north
carolina teams um
fractured effects their entire team who
did all of the
affects makeup through justin
and um i also want to say that
there are tens of thousands of cross
people just like us
who are below the line
who
come into work every day and work long
and hard
and
and who never
get the opportunity to have this kind of
recognition
and i just hope that
um each and every day that on set
everyone takes a moment to just look
around and look at all those talented
people who work so hard to um make
beautiful films with all of you so
um
thank you so much everybody this means
so much thank you
[Applause]
you